[Music]
so
some of it lunch
yes oh they're so cute but they're just
they have they like the curls
thank you
my name is griffin mcconnell i i was
born
in the september 2004. my life story's
been a very
up and down kind of thing it's like you
you think it's gonna be good and then
everything collapses
[Music]
i know i have seizures i it stinks that
i have seizures
that's very lovely i was diagnosed with
epilepsy when
i was i think five yes
when he was four before all the medical
stuff started happening we had one of
those
goofy ten and one games that was like
chinese checkers and you know
and checkers and it also was chess and
griffin asked me to teach him how to
play chess
it was very funny the chess was kind of
a major part
of my surgeries because it was
memorizing and i wanted to figure out
what
this game was and so when time passed my
chest was getting better but also my
seizures were getting
worse and he was sitting in the car and
he wouldn't respond to me
and i started yelling at him griffin
what's wrong come on we gotta go
and it was just weird we tried to do
medicine and we tried to do use a lot of
drugs to make my seizures come down but
it didn't work
when you fail enough of the medicines
then you finally become a candidate for
brain surgery
[Music]
that's what you called it let's see it
bring it
[Music]
he had his first two brain surgeries in
2012.
one was a grid surgery where they take
the grid and stick it straight onto the
brain
and then try to figure out where those
seizures are coming from a year later he
had
a left functional hemispherectomy which
is where they disconnect the two sides
of the brain
and take out some of the tissue in the
left hemisphere
[Music]
chess has played a huge role in this
family we're not doing this
no we're pulling bullet chests that's
what
that's that's just means that if you're
white you lose
chess is always a passion of mine i've
done it a long time
and so after the left hemispherectomy
i started to regain my thinking and my
abilities
why am i moving so fast
[Laughter]
yes
i did try to um play chess like
we've mentioned but like i i just
i thought well i did it for a couple
reasons just to see
try something new to see if i liked it
also to try to get a little closer
with my brothers because i mean we're
close but like sully and griffin are
much closer than me
i just sent you a challenge sullivan
i have your face in there
he was really happy to play again
because he'd lost playing chess for
about a year
um and he'll tell you about this he
feels like that's where sullivan his
younger brother cheated him and got
ahead of him in raiding
because sullivan kept playing griffin
couldn't we played a lot before
griffin uh was disabled and we still
play a lot after he was disabled
really the hardest the hard part of my
brother's disability is that
really he can do everything i can except
it just takes him
more time okay hold on
uh all right quickly i'm going to check
that out that actually i think that was
a fortress
it's time to check hold on
let's see was that correct was it a
fortress
oh my god it is it is
okay like wait i played that like so
terribly
so how did i what after knight c too i
have i'm
okay so i have to play
griffin made expert when he was 12.
and then he's just been stuck uh on
expert
which is he's really pushing to make
master
and part of that i think is because he
was also trying to learn how to read and
write and do school
so trying to take all that brain power
when you only have half of the brain
to do all of that i think is partly why
he hasn't gotten as fast
a big part of chess is everyone has an
ego
and everyone if they want to learn how
to play chess
they have to know they they're going to
lose
honestly you've got to give nakamura a
great deal of credit on chess.com
because and i'm not saying that to suck
up to chess.com either but
god love them because they're doing
these these new tournaments these pog
championships have you watched any of
those
oh you should have yeah they're all even
kind of things so they have
non-chess players but they're really
great
uh at fortnight or they're really great
and they have a bunch of followers on
another platform and they they pair them
with a nakamura or a
you know a high rated player and that
player works with them for like
20 30 days you know gets them to a 1200
level or something they're
there of and then they have a
championship where they play and
nakamura just does comments understand
why he made those moves
but isn't it what you said before about
like this this
cycle where it's like when you're when
the other guy's moving fast you move
fast when they're moving
you move slower and so you know you're
just watching
rank amateurs play chess and it's
hilarious because they miss
easy checkmates they blunder pieces
right and left but they're really
serious about it so like the guy who
played the mountain
on a game of thrones uh he's a chess
player now he was in the last pog
championships and
there's i mean there's something really
enthralling about watching someone of
his stature and size
hunkered down you know making you know
cussing because he missed a fork you
know or whatever
uh okay it didn't start well
uh but it's going well now he's taking
the center
uh i'm just gonna castle i'm just gonna
castle here
i like that i like that i like castling
yeah
bringing my pieces to the center uh
staying calm he does this in our lessons
okay at six o'clock on this saturday
uh you are going to have a interview
with hikaru nakamura in the interview
yes he's going to zoom you're going to
have a zoom call just with the karo
nakamura
what yes that's a lot of pressure
on me i love carl
i'm his biggest fan team has entered the
waiting room for this
meeting so should i accept
so i say omit is that what it is
okay i'm ready
can you hear me now yes what's up
good good good um i uh
i'm feeling pretty nervous but that's
kind of
cool when your favorite person is hakaro
nakamura
so i'm very excited but nervous you know
what i mean
so all right cool so um
do you have any like least favorite part
about chess
for a long time i feel like it's sort of
been like we
we idolize these top players we try to
say how smart the top players are at the
game of chess
instead of just uh instead of trying to
be inclusive saying well it's you know
there might be people who are really
good at it but anybody can play the game
you don't have to be smart to be good at
it
but a lot of people sort of they they
figure well if you're if you're not a
great shots for then who cares like
you know it doesn't matter so you start
judging the self-worth or what someone
what someone does based on their rating
instead of just being a person thank you
very much hakaro
um no problem i'm just uh
it's exciting you know what i mean yeah
no that's
which which olympia did you play in
though i'm kind of curious now
he played in the olympia the online
olympiad um which was the very first
ever online olympiad for people with uh
dis disabilities
colorado is not it's not it's not big
for
people with disabilities who play chess
griffin had a tremendous tournament in
spite of
having seizures he was bored two and he
scored
a four out of seven points which is
every single person he played was
at least 150 to uh
400 points higher rated than him that
was the point
um where i wanted to be
something to inspire
[Music]
a great icon for me is thomas luther
he's a grandmaster but he has a
disability
and he is trying to create all of these
tournaments that i've been
into and so for me
i want to be like thomas luther
he went six years seizure-free we think
and now he's having seizures again
it was kind of heartbreaking because i
was doing
so many things like wonderful things
and now it came back
one of the games he lost quite badly he
had a seizure
the last eight minutes of the game the
problem is that there's a clock
ticking and so all of a sudden my time
went to 15 minutes to 5 minutes out of
nowhere
and so these seizures are really messing
up my play
there's a surgery coming up and we're
trying well griffin dad and mom
are trying to decide whether they should
do it or they shouldn't he's going to go
in for an anatomical hemispherectomy
which is they take
everything out of that left hemisphere
my biggest fear and i
i think griffin's biggest fear is that
either he'll die in one because that is
always a possibility
or he has to have this brain surgery and
it doesn't work i think that's
more scary than even him passing away in
the surgery is that it doesn't work
again in my opinion surgery is the only
way
that i can feel like
the seizures have been gone
[Music]
i just hope that he and sally
stay happy with the chess because
they commit a lot of time and energy to
test so
yeah i guess i just want them to be
happy
[Music]
griffin is a miracle to me and i just
think he's he's my hero and i try to be
as
good of a person because he's so strong
and he's taught me a lot
[Music]
it's really hard to take anything else
super seriously i mean in terms of the
small stuff
which is a blessing
[Music]
right here
and if you made a mistake
[Music]
you